julien assange un procès historique pour
un homme qui risque d'être extradé vers
les états unis et d'écoper 175 ans de
prison pour tenter de décrypter les
enjeux d'un tel procès nous sommes avec
françois corbère de l'association robin
des lois et viktor dedaj fondateur du
site le grand soir messieurs messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
aussi relaté france alors avant de vous
l'entendre je vous propose de démarrer
avec ce tweet d'eric dupond-moretti
c'était en fait en février dernier il
était alors avocats de julian assange
nous allons demander à rencontrer le
président de la république dans les
jours qui viennent pour ne pas dire dans
les heures qui viennent
alors françois cau robert votre
association robin des lois souhaite donc
que le fondateur de wikileaks obtiennent
l'asile politique en france
eric dupond moretti est aujourd'hui et
garde des sceaux alors on a vu ce tweet
est ce que cela peut aider votre cause
écoutez je dirais que dupont moretti est
devenu un adversaire
nous nous battons nous depuis un an avec
un projet extrêmement technique met au
point par emmanuel ludot qui étaient nos
avocats habituel qui tint un très bon
spécialiste des questions pénales et
procédurales pour obtenir l'asile c'est
à dire qu' il ya des façons d'obtenir
l'asile en france moi que c'est
important pour éclaircir le débat au
départ vous avez l'asile qui est
accordée par le président de la
république et localement on appelle ça
la zil constitutionnel c'est ce qu'a
demandé dupond moretti
la requête est encore avocat brièvement
des changes le 20 février dans une
conférence de presse retentissante eia
l'asile qu'on obtient par l'ofpra qui
est l'organisme national qui est que
n'importe quel demandeur d'asile
s'adresse qu il faut mallié au maroc il
est réfugié en france
il demande la zea l'ofpra qui se trouve
juridiquement à créteil tribunal de
créteil fontenay mais pour pouvoir
demander l'asile à l'ofpra
il faut être sur le territoire français
et c'est l'enjeu que nous portons depuis
quelques mois jusqu'à présent elle fait
très discrètement en le proposant aux
avocats d'assange
pour qu' il ya une dérogation qui soit
obtenu en justice ça peut faire très
vite pour que je viens simples soient
autorisés à déposer une demande d'asile
à l'ofpra et non pas en suppliant le
président de la république qui veut qui
veut pas enfin vous connaissez les
hésitations et puis quelques années là
dessus puisque hollande avait refusé une
demande qui avait été formulée dans le
monde
bon donc nous avons l'intention de
saisir et à le faire dans les jours qui
viennent en référé le tribunal de
créteil pour que justin st je suis
autorisé pour que nous soyons autorisés
à demander une dérogation je vous passe
le détail c'est assez technique et nous
pensions depuis un an qu'il faut
demander l'asile que c'est la seule
solution
avec ce procès qui est enlisé avec ce
délibéré qui comme par hasard est fixée
après la fin du brésil
c'est à dire le 4 janvier pourquoi parce
que l'asile permet actuellement l'état
du traité de dublin
si imaginons demain que le présence d'un
public accorde l'asile à julian assange
l'angleterre est obligé de le remettre à
la france y aurait un bras de fer
diplomatique je passe les détails mais
du fait des accords de dublin
l'angleterre serait obligé de le laisser
revenir en froid mais il reste trois
mois donc il reste extrêmement peu de
temps pour obtenir l'asile
donc quand dupond moretti a annoncé
j'étais à la conférence de presse avec
beaucoup d'émotion qu'il allait demander
l'asile immédiatement sous peu dans
l'urgence on était tous d'accord c'était
ce qu'il fallait faire en dépit des
hésitations des avocats anglais qui
disait on attend de voir le procès
commence à tourner très bien mais nous
on disait il faut que ils arrivent en
disant je vais demander l'asile
bravo on applaudit j'ai aucune
antipathie j'admirais le grand avocat
qu'il était le cas aujourd'hui en tout
cas aujourd'hui ça ne veut ça ne peut
pas bouger de maintenant il est garde
des sceaux d'à côté on l'a mis dans un
article du monde le 21 août on a publié
une lettre ouverte on en avait eu assez
d'attendre puisqu'il a complètement
oublié ses déclarations fracassantes et
autres et il nous a répondu qu'il nous
recevrait quand il aurait le temps au
vatican serait donc on a rendu publique
on lui a rappelé ses souvenirs mais
c'était au moins d'août
il a écouté il ya quatre mois devant 100
journalistes me l'avait dit que vous
aviez demandé l'asile d'urgence parce
qu'effectivement il était arrivé de
londres 10 ans qui n'était pas bien
qu'il fallait d'urgence de man et puis
et je pense que c'est scandaleux que
celui qui a été un grand avocat et trahi
cette course parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'explication en août a fait dire
attendez il réfléchit au cas jaune
alliés qui me la poser la question
frontalement depuis le mois d'août mais
il faudrait la lui posèrent on va
essayer dans les quinze jours qui
viennent de la plus posée qu'est ce que
vous attendez on n'est pas compétent lui
pour accorder l'asile mais il a
évidemment le flux directs avec le
président avec lui pour faire
effectivement bouger les choses
entendre victor déjà d'un fondateur du
site le grand soir peut-être sur le fond
alors les avocats de julian assange
aujourd'hui rappelle le caractère
journalistique des travaux de julian
assange
pourquoi il n'a pas dépassé
effectivement son rôle de journaliste
selon vous pourquoi il n'a pas dépassé
selon le journal et journalistes écoutez
y compris dans les chefs d'inculpation
présentée par les états unis au mois de
février dernier les deux les faits qui
lui sont reprochés étaient décrits dans
les chefs d'inculpation décrivez c'est
pas moi qui parle ce sont les plus
grands journalistes d'investigation de
notre époque qui le disaient c'est
bizarre mais ça décrit exactement une de
nos journées de travail il n'y a rien de
spécial danser dans ces chefs
d'inculpation
mais ce qu'il faut constater c'est que
entre temps les américains ont changé
deux fois de fusil d épaule
lorsqu'il en juin août
ils ont présenté de nouvelles
accusations contre julian assange
d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient présenté
d'abord à la presse par sans même les
avoir transmis à la justice britannique
et lors des procès on a insisté un
phénomène où les avocats américains vous
pour le gouvernement américain ou encore
une changer deuxième fois d'angle
d'attac en changeant encore les chefs
d'inculpation grand dam des témoins qui
étaient préparés à a plaidé sur les
anciens accusations et des témoins qui
sont vus remettre des dossiers de plus
de 300 pages le matin même de leurs
témoignages en direct donc la farce à
qui a démarré il ya longtemps ce a
continué il est clair maintenant à point
des témoins qui sont passés les uns
après les autres des témoins de haute
tenue des témoins que là
encore ont tenté désespérément de
ridiculiser et de remettre en cause
leurs compétences qui n'ont pas flanché
qu'ils n'ont pas et qui ne sont pas
laissés faire part face à des parages de
questions roulant pour des contre
interrogatoires qui ont duré parfois
quatre heures alors que la défense
n'avait droit qu'à une demi-heure pour
interroger les deux témoins on sent bien
qu'il y avait une sorte de parti pris
ici de que de thés la part de la juge
ils n'ont pas flanché ils ont été bien
un niveau exceptionnel et ils ont
clairement démontré de a jusqu'à z que
julian assange était bien un journaliste
alors messieurs heures d'ailleurs je
tiens un gîte pour terminer c'est que
les américains sont arrivés maintenant à
la une situation qui complètement
surréaliste selon les mots de à
l'exemple des secouristes qui a sorti un
article tendre et consciencieux news il
ya deux trois jours c'est donc
complètement surréaliste dans la mesure
où des derniers jours on a vu les
procureurs si vous voulez américain
reprochés à julian assange des crimes
dont il était incapable de citer un seul
exemple concret c'est à dire que le
grand reproche maintenant qui lui est
faite c'est d'avoir révélé les noms et
d'avoir mis des billes en danger tout en
étant incapable de citer un seul nom au
lion d'angers on est ici de voir un
procès pénal ou quelqu'un les 175 ans de
prison et les accusateurs sont même pas
capables de montrer non non seulement le
l'arme du crime mais de désigner de quel
type d'armes il s'agit alors pas ça
alors messieurs peut-être de nouvelles
révélations à venir je vous propose
d'écouter le rédacteur en chef de
wikileaks
vers la fin de la journée
le juge venait sa barrette serre a
décidé de donner l'anonymat à deux
témoins importants qui doivent toujours
témoigner ici l'un d'espagne un ancien
employé de bus et globale la compagnie
qui explosent et julian et espionner les
interactions de julian avec ses avocats
dans l'ambassade équatorienne et nous
entendons bien sûr pour qui ils
travaillaient vraiment qui payer les
factures
quel intérêt il servait et bien sûr nous
savons que c'était les institutions
américaines
une institution composée de trois
lettres qui cherchait julian et qui a
décidé de le faire tomber ses anciens
employés témoigneront des plans qui ont
été discutés à l'ambassade équatorienne
empoisonné de julian assange le
kidnapper faire n'importe quoi pour le
sortir de là françois quand vers ces
révélations et elle peut être ça peut
être un avantage pour julian assange et
ses avocats selon vous écoutez je pense
pas être démentie par autre qu un but et
c'est connu des gens qui s'intéressent à
ça puisque la presse espagnole à révérer
déjà tant de contenus qui sont
confirmées aujourd'hui mais on sait que
a faim il a été écouté par tout filmé et
enregistré dans l'ambassade donc c'est
pas vraiment un scoop bon que la défense
le présente aujourd'hui avec les deux
témoins qui sont évoqués pour ça
renforce l'argument mais je crois que
c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que ça je n'ai rien à
faire en prison alors il est l'instar d'
alerte il est journaliste seriak
rapporte julien lamy il est journaliste
évidemment je rappelle qu'il ya dix ans
les plus grands journaux du monde ont
publié une partie des fameux câbles
diplomatiques avec des commentaires que
ce soit le monde que soient les plus
grands journaux et à fin juin
à l'époque considéré comme un
journaliste alors est ce cas on peut
même pas discuter je crois que notre
invité a totalement raison bien sûr de
dire qu'il n'ya pas deux ehpad
espionnage tout ça il a fait un travail
de journaliste
après ce qu'ils étaient un peu
journalistes beaucoup journaliste
lanceur d'alert bon c'est pas vraiment
la question
tout ça est très secondaire par rapport
à huy viktor dedaj justement est ce
qu'il ya un silence gênant qui éludent
cette actualité en france c'est un
constat quand vous ne comprenez c'est
incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible parce que c'est
la sphère de presse le plus important de
mémoire d'homme les enjeux sont
éminemment important d
invisible notamment d'après les
développements dans les dernières
audiences où les procureurs américains
je les appelle des procureurs et les
avocats et les procureurs ont cette fois
ci est carrément admis ce qu'il n'y ait
il n'y a pas si longtemps c'est qu'ils
se réservent le droit les états unis se
réserve le droit maintenant de
poursuivre n'importe quel journaliste à
travers le monde
pour finir et de journalistes comment
l'expliquer je n'en sais rien c'est une
affaire qui est c'est une histoire
parallèle à l'histoire du conseil du
julian assange qui reste à écrire selon
moi c'est la position l'attitude des
journalistes en général à pain dans le
surtout dans les médias mainstream à
part quelques exceptions dont vous
faites partie et je pense que cette
histoire reste à écrire mais je voudrais
dire que le caractère politique du
procès de julian assange ne fait plus
aucun doute et ce depuis le début en
fait il faut rappeler que je viens d'un
sage n'a jamais été sous juridiction
américaine
le fait même qu'il vienne le chercher
ose prétendre venir le chercher était un
acte politique l'extraterritorialité n'a
pas de valeur juridique c'est un acte
politique par définition
julian assange est donc victime d'une
tentative d'enlèvement déguisé sous
forme d'un procès politique pour rester
un petit peu élégant dans l'occident
mais c'est à peu près l'équivalent de
lui mettre une cagoule sur la tête le
ballon et dans le coffre d'une bagnole
landais sur un terrain vague et tout le
reste tout le reste était forcément du
même tonneau
il ne pouvait pas en être autrement
lorsque les accusations ne porte pas sur
des faits réels mais sur des motifs
politiques
alors qu'on ne pouvait pas admettre des
motifs politiques parce que je rappelle
que le le le
l'accord d'extradition dans les états
unis et l'angle entre l'angleterre et
les états unis ne permet pas d
extradition pour des motifs politiques
ont il s'agit d'un procès politique et
on a vu pendant des semaines
les procureurs américains tenter
désespérément de trouver une branche
auquel s'accrocher pour essayer de faire
croire que julien assange avait commis
un acte criminel de pas
activité purement journalistique c'est
un scandale en soi le deuxième scandale
par dessus ce scandale en soi c'est le
silence des médias et des journalistes
en général il n'y a pratiquement
personne pour couvrir cette affaire je
rappelle que les 40 ong ont été
expulsées nommément de la part de cette
mystérieuse juge ne pas les séparer de
serre dont amnesty international qu'ils
voulaient envoyer un observateur et je
profite de l'antenne pour lancer un
appel reçu aujourd'hui amnesty
international justement je pense que
c'est assez de tergiversations je vais
dans le sens de monsieur corbère c'était
une affaire politique et c'est
clairement une affaire politique
ce pourrait ne pas être à leurs yeux une
affaire politique au début parce que la
complexité de la sphère pourrait donner
l'impression que mais aujourd'hui c'est
clair net et précis
julian assange est un prisonnier
politique françois qui s'attend à
amnesty international de déclaré julian
assange par un communiqué au paraguay
formelle un prisonnier politique
actuellement enfermé dans une prison de
haute sécurité allons françois corbère
le mot de la fin vous rejoignez les
propos de viktor dedaj bien sûr pourrait
parler pendant des heures sur le court
ce fan analyse et la nôtre sont les
mêmes
moi je pense que la réponse à la
question que vous posiez sur le silence
de la presse française s'explique assez
bien historiquement tout simplement
parce que c'est très loin
nous militants juristes on a suivi
l'épisode de l'ambassade mais c'est très
très vieux faut pas oublier que ça
remonte à il ya dix ans le les câbles
donc je pense qu'il ya eu un temps très
long pendant lequel était dans
l'ambassade où personnes globalement
s'intéressait à sa situation est donc la
presse française nous on le voit depuis
le mois d'août au tournant on est sorti
du bois avec l'idée d'une procédure
qu'on va lancer dans les jours qui
viennent à créteil en essayant d'appeler
les journalistes un par un ah oui c'est
vrai bon effectivement c'est pas de la
mauvaise volonté je pense pas qu'ils
aient un complot de la presse française
mais je voudrais lancer un appel ce soir
à tous les gens qui nous écoutent
il ya un scandale majeur il ya un homme
qui garde des sceaux qui est eric dupond
moretti
c'est pas rien dans la république bon
cet homme s'est engagé devant le monde
entier le 20 février
j'étais à la conférence de presse à dire
à 5 du temps danger ces politiques tout
ce que je viens de dire
notre invité on est tout à fait d'accord
là dessus il a dit l'ancien y avait sans
journalistes irrite un la stalle j'en ai
encore l'émotion quand on réécoute la
conférence de presse je vais dans le car
qui vient dans les jours qui viennent
alerte elle présente à lui au mois
d'août quatre mois après nous posons la
question dans le par le biais d'une
lettre dans le monde qui a été reprise
par l'afp et ça en disant monsieur
dupont moretti recevez nous on voulait
savoir m et cet homme est aujourd'hui le
garde des sceaux et que demain après
demain tous les journalistes y ont
prouvé qu'ils peuvent l'approcher qui
peuvent lui poser des questions lui dise
monsieur le ministre
qu en est-il vous êtes engagés aux yeux
du monde entier vous engager vis-à-vis
de nos journalistes ou faites vous on
sait très bien que vous n'avez pas le
pouvoir d'accorder l'asile mais voyez le
président est lui assez facilement
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire parce
qu'on est persuadé depuis début nous que
c'est la seule chose que soit le verdict
qui sera rendu le 4 janvier aura un
appel d'un des deux côtés ça peut durer
encore très longtemps
et pendant ce temps là il ya un homme
qui n'a rien à faire en prison qui peut
y mourir
il ya un homme qui était avocat et
encore quelques mois un des plus grands
avocats de france je le croyais je j'ai
été heureux de voir nommer on était
contents on se dit souvent c'est
quelqu'un qui va dans le bon sens
cet homme il faut que tous les
journalistes dans les jours qui viennent
quel courage
merci monsieur le ministre qu'est ce que
vous avez fait ce problème c'est rien
mais c'est pas futile devant 100
journalistes du monde entier encore une
fois dans les plus grands journaux une
conférence de presse fracassante que
vous pouvez retrouver sur facebook dans
l'est avec organisée par reporters sans
frontières
je crois que c'est la question à poser
pour que toi un détonateur un grand
merci
on va devoir rendre l'antenne le temps
qui nous est imparti est bientôt
terminée donc un grand merci en tout cas
à tous les deux d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci à vous françois corbère
je rappelle que vous êtes de
l'association robin des lois merci à
vous viktor dedaj fondateur du site le
grand soir et